[Musique]
bonjour patrick houssel bonjour 7 le
directeur de l'agencé régionale de santé
sur marty comme hier dans son caddie
patrick houssel la compréhension
désolation tristesse salve de critiques
après cette nouvelle tombée vendredi
soir le siège sud martinique est sous
administration provisoire ce sera à
compter du 1er décembre
on veut comprendre patrick houssel
comment on en est arrivé là cela veut
dire quoi déjà être sous administration
la procédure d'administration provisoire
répond à une situation une situation qui
est grave et préoccupante
une situation qui s'est dégradée c'est
une procédure qui est comprise dans le
code de la santé publique qui est bien
bien proto colisée que qui est
déclenchée par le directeur général de
la rs alors on a entendu beaucoup de
choses hein par exemple que l'emploi
serait menacée aussi h jusqu'au 1er mai
me remettre en question la fusion qui
s'est opéré il ya quelques années au
sein du chu de martinique
non non il n'est pas question de mettre
en oeuvre un plan social
il n'est pas question de revenir sur la
fusion des établissements que vous
évoquez il faut entendre les malades
il faut écouter les patients certains
patients il faut entendre les personnels
il faut entendre les médecins que nous
disent les les patients ils nous disent
cela ne marche pas bien
nous attendons nous avons des délais on
as portent nos médicaments deux fois ce
sera elle n'est pas assurée c'est pas la
règle les médecins nous disent ne
pouvons pas mettre en oeuvre notre
projet médical et les personnels nous
font part de leurs conditions de travail
donc nous sommes à la rs à l' écoute de
tout cela donc on voit bien que cet
hôpital est à la peine alors c'est
d'autant plus paradoxal parce que c'est
un établissement le chu de martinique
qui a des qualités qui a des atouts
c'est un établissement de référence dans
la caraïbe c'est un établissement qui
est enviée sociale et le tour je vais
vous dire c'est à l'établissement qui
est envié par tous les pays de la
caraïbe
c'est un établissement qui vient de
présenter un projet médical qui est
résolument tournée vers quelle place ils
soutenons cet établissement est
aujourd'hui placée sous administration
pourquoi on en est arrivé là vous ai
fait part d'un certain nombre de
remarques patrick houssel des situations
dénoncées par les syndicats depuis
plusieurs années
les cadences de fernard pour les équipes
la dégradation des la bâtisse des
bâtiments des services
alors c'est ce que je vais vous dire
c'est d'autant plus paradoxal que nous
avons beaucoup soutenu cet établissement
vous le savez nous avons apporté des
moyens les moyens considérables
nous avons recruté des personnels jeu
dizaines de millions injectés chaque
année en plus du budget normalement à
louis des effectifs supplémentaires
également je veux vous dire par exemple
qu'il y a aujourd'hui plus de personnel
dans ce chu qu'il y en avait avant la
fusion il nous fait une belle jambe
patrick ou c'est parce que lorsqu'on
entend ça aujourd'hui comme n'arrive à
cette situation ce qui a forcément
quelque chose qui n'a pas fonctionné
alors crois exactement alors c'est un
hôpital qui n'a pas fait évoluer ses
organisations
et c'est pour raison pour laquelle nous
demandons à cette nouvelle gouvernance
de mettre en oeuvre un plan d'action un
plan d'action qui va faire évoluer
procéder à des ajustements dans la
répartition des lits dans la répartition
des agents entre les services entre les
services administratifs et techniques et
les services médicaux
c'est un établissement qui doit se
moderniser
s'adapter faire évoluer son offre le
choix si on en est arrivé là c'est à
cause de ce qu'on appelle le co perd
mots que le comité interministériel de
performance et de modernisation de
l'offre de soins qui devait veiller au
bon investissement au bon fonctionnement
à une offre qui répondrait à la demande
ça n'a pas marché alors le comité de
performance qui se réunit donc au
ministère a au contraire pour objet
d'aider des établissements en difficulté
à marcher
écoutez de de faire un diagnostic nos
stick
qu'est ce qu'y at-il dans ce diagnostic
le père monodie attendait nous devons
nous interroger sur la pertinence de
certains investissements réalisés au
cours de ces dernières années
vous devez vous interroger sur
l'organisation de votre offre de soins
vous devez comme dans tous les
établissements
transformez vos lits d'hospitalisation
complète n'est pas un faucon constat ça
n'a pas marché
l'état que vous représentez patrick
aussel a sa part de responsabilité dans
cette situation vous de la rs vous
regardez comment ça fonctionnait non ça
n'a pas fonctionné puisque nous sommes
sous administration désormais danse ou
ministration provisoire ce n'était pas
une mise sous tutelle mais je veux
revenir là dessus parce que il ya des
corrections à apporter ce qui a été dit
ce n'est pas l'état qui va diriger
l'hôpital c'est une nouvelle gouvernance
qui se met en place
quand je dis nouvelle gouvernance n'est
pas simplement des administrateurs
provisoires mais c'est la mise en oeuvre
d'une organisation de gestion de
l'établissement avec les professionnels
les cadres et les médecins à ce désir
ouvrir de là bas et ici les ceux qui
sont appliqués sur le terrain il sera
demandé à ses d'administration
provisoire de mettre en oeuvre cette
nouvelle gouvernance avec tous ceux qui
sont appliqués sur le terrain simple de
l'avoir fait avant vous posez la
question je veux j'ai fait le constat
que ça n'était pas le cas et c'est pour
cela que j'ai déclenché cette 7,7 cette
procédure
voilà c'est alors lorsque lorsqu'on
regarde tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment concernant le chu on l'a dit les
syndicats qui n'ont pas arrêté de bouder
de faire la gueule de critiquer ce qui
se passait lorsqu'on entend par exemple
cette communauté hospitalière qui
décident de de se prendre mais qui évite
la population à se mobiliser autour
d'elle pour pouvoir avoir une meilleure
offre de santé à la martinique
et lorsqu'on entend tout ce beau monde
d'hier les meilleurs spécialistes les
meilleurs spécialistes des affaires
martiniquaise a sonné martiniquais eux
mêmes quelque part ils oseraient ils
veulent dire surtout que il ya des
décisions qui sont prises à paris
peut-être pour des établissements de la
grandeur de la salpêtrière par exemple
qui ne sont pas applicables ici en
martinique et les décisions prises par
le ministère de la santé comme celle que
vous venez d'évoquer sont aussi des
décisions au profit du chu de martinique
lorsque le ministère de la santé décide
après réunion de côte du coc permet
d'allouer les sommes que vous connaissez
enfin 90 millions d'une année à l'autre
voilà de financer une partie de
l'investissement nécessaire au nouveau
plateau technique est ce que vous pensez
que les autres établissements de la
france hexagonale bénéficient des mêmes
dotations je ne le crois pas monsieur
viande dans la micro d'argent on a mis
trop d'argent par exemple sur les
infrastructures n'a pas pensé à la
philosophie au projet médical par ex je
le dis pas qu'on a mis
trop d'argent dans temps dans les
infrastructures jeudi que le ministère a
pris conscience qu'il y avait des
spécificités en martinique et l'argent
c'est de l'argent jeté par la fenêtre
c'est tout c'est sans qu'on a évoqué non
ce n'est pas de l'argent dans tout ce
qui est versé au profit de la santé des
martiniquaises et des martiniquais n'est
pas de l'argent versé jeter par la
fenêtre
loin de là non parce qu'on essaie de
comprendre à quoi ça a servi cet argent
pour arriver à cette situation le chu
aujourd'hui est confronté à des
difficultés dont les origines tiennent à
plusieurs niveaux il ya d'abord des des
causes qui sont partagées par l'ensemble
des établissements
ça va pas par l'ensemble et par une
majorité des hobbies les dettes des
établissements qui ont des déficits
structurels
d d d d d une offre qui n'est pas
complètement ajuster à la demande ça on
trouve ça dans quelques établissements
s'est partagé par le chu de martinique
il ya des spéciales il ya des
difficultés qui tiennent à la
spécificité ultramarines sacoche noire
des états ou traitements sur des
territoires et 3 donc avec des bassins
de population qui nous est très
restreint et qui apporteront peut de 2,2
de recettes à l'établissement d'où
l'idée de la fusion par exemple la
martinique la fusion des trois
établissements effectivement mais cette
fusion qui est une belle idée force est
de constater aujourd'hui que les
objectifs attendus ne sont pas
complètement au résultat qu'on a
fusionné les dettes parce qu'on a
fusionné tout ce qu'on devait aux
fournisseurs
il y avait 2,2 comment deux objectifs un
objectif d'optimisation de l'offre de
soins et un objectifs d'efficience
aujourd'hui vous venez de faire et a
donc eu du déficit ça déficit qui n'a
pas qui n'a pas disparu qui a même eu
progresser et sur sur l'optimisation
nous devons regretté que l'activité
aujourd'hui du nouveau chu et moindre
qu'avant la fusion
donc il y a eu une évolution qui est
inattendue surprenante
je termine si vous voulez bien parce que
dans les niveaux d'explication de cette
situation il ya des spécificités
ultramarines
et puis il ya les particularités de ce
16 juin
la particularité à chu c'est un hôpital
encore une fois qui n'a pas fait évoluer
son organisation des soins
il y a des petits services ce que l'on
veut c'est en termes des génériques et
nous avons énormément pêcher en termes
d'organisation de l'offre
oui c'est vrai qu'il y a très peu
d'ambulatoire c'est le chu qui met en
oeuvre le moins d'ambulatoire c'est des
petits bouts de service donc ce que l'on
dit au co perd mots ce que le dico père
mot pardon c'est qu'il faut fusionner il
faut transformer il faut rapprocher
c'est d'ailleurs jamais écarté valoriser
le projet né de notre de notre
établissement qui peut permettre les
accouchements également quelques
kilomètres ça je parlais tout à l'heure
de la pertinence des investissements
réalisés au cours des dernières années
effectivement des services comme ceux
que vous venez de dire est tout
simplement dit kiki qui ont été mis fin
il n'y a qu'une maternité sur le dans la
zone que vous dites là puisque le chu
compte de maternité trinité et
mais fait l'administration pendant six
mois ce sera suffisant pour avoir une
ébauche de solution définitive c'est une
administration qui va préparer donc la
nomination du nouveau directeur général
qui interviendra dans six mois merci
patrick houssel d'avoir été ce matin
avec nos on rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur de l'agencé régionale de santé
que vous exprimer ce matin dans son
caddie concernant la situation chu bonne
journée
[Musique]